if you have just joined us you are
watching turkish President Recep type
erawan and Russian President Vladimir
Putin the biggest lines come out of that
is that a midnight ceasefire or a
ceasefire to come into effect at
midnight has been announced for in the
province in northern Syria so Hashem
what did you make of what came out of
those talks there is a ceasefire I mean
do you think this one is any more likely
to hold than the previous ones we've
seen what I think what they have
achieved today in Moscow is quite
significant for the time being because
until a few hours ago there were huge
concerns that they might come up with an
agreement about a ceasefire because
fighting flared up a few hours ago in
the city of Soraka with the turkey
backed rebels pounding government
positions in the city but this is quite
a crucial moment for the two key players
Russia and Turkey I mean you can hear
from the final communique by both
leaders that they remain completely
divided about Syria President Vladimir
Putin was very critical of a key faction
group in the opposition which is at the
hairy regime describing it as a
terrorist organization and justifying
the military are the actions of the
Syrian government as legitimate and
blaming HGS for all the problems in
Italy province on the other hand where
President Erdogan was talking he was
saying that Assad is to blame for the
offensive in Syria and for in Italy and
is to blame for the displacement of a
million refugees on the border with
Turkey and I think they decided for a
moment to set aside those differences
about the narrative and agree on the
three terms of the ceasefire what is
significant about that is Kim is that
particularly the idea of the safe
corridor corridor along m4 ym4 because
it links Latakia to Soraka and both
countries will be banning conducting
patrols along the way north and
which means that this is going to be a
pivotal moment to prevent the Syrian
army from crossing that m4 into the city
of Idlib so they I think from from from
a Turkish perspective this is quite an
important thing I think the delicate
task facing the two countries in the
near future is will Russia on one hand
be able to rein in President Bashar
al-assad forces who have been saying in
the past few days that they are adamant
they will continue their push to take
over the city of Idlib and the province
which is the rebels last stronghold in
Syria at the same time will the Turks be
able to rein in the Syrian factions who
have lost significant territory in the
past few weeks and who seem to be
adamant at the same time that they would
like to claim back those areas because
the the when they lost those areas
hundreds of thousands of people are
stranded now on the border with Turkey
it was interesting what you mentioned
there about the m4 and m5 highways I
mean I'm I'm thinking how long can this
truce ceasefire particularly around that
stretch those strategic highways how
long can that continue because like you
said Bashar al Assad's forces they want
to retake all of Syria I mean how long
can that hold well I mean from today I
mean when you look at the choreography
of the or that of that announcement
today between air Doha and Putin you get
the impression that these are the two
key players who hold the keys to any
permanent solution to the crisis in
Syria everyone else has taken a
backstage position from the EU to the
United States of America since 2017
Turkey and Russia decided to set aside
their differences and team up and that
was very instrumental if it paved the
way for the first Astana agreement in
2007 17 that paved the way for the
demilitarized zones in in Italy and then
2018 the observation post and the safe
corridors and on October last October
the Russians and the Turks agreed on the
area that stretches from
via Taurus a lion which is in the north
eastern part of Syria so in getting this
in you you get this indication that the
Russians and the Turks will definitely
have a bigger say in shaping the future
of Syria came however when it comes to
the permanent solution to the political
solution to the crisis the two countries
have different narratives President
Bashar al-assad has called for
parliamentary elections in April the
Turkish government says that's not
legitimate it has to be under the aegis
of the international community and the
opposition should be included in those
elections but when we change the whole
framework including drafting of a new
constitution and rewriting the whole
political establishment in Syria Russia
on the other hand backs President Bashar
al-assad and says this is something that
has to be decided by the legitimate
Authority in Syria being President
Bashar al-assad and I think the two
leaders do understand that for the time
being they'd rather maintain those
recent gains particularly the ceasefire
to be announced midnight and leave the
talk about the political settlement for
another opportunity when you have all
the elements conducive to a genuine
political solution that will and a
conflict that has been going on for now
nine years Hashem there have been some
Turkish losses significant losses as far
as far as the Turkish people are
concerned how do you think this
ceasefire announcement is going to go
down in Turkey among the population and
also among the politicians because they
have been very divided
well if tonight there was no
announcement there was no deal that
would put that would have put massive
pressure on President Recep Tayyip
Erdogan because once back here in Turkey
it will be extremely difficult for him
to to convince the people about the
rationale behind signing sending troops
into into the province of Italy but
today with that announcement that the
church have managed to and this is
basically what they have been saying
over the last few days they have
saying that our aim is to convince
Vladimir Putin to give us a safe
corridor deem a safe corridor a
demilitarized zone and also a ceasefire
to be implemented and the got what they
wanted now turkey remains keep saying
that the reason why it sent troops in
Italy was for two reasons first of all
and this was repeated today many times
by President Recep Tayyip Erdogan he
said that the Syrian government was
launching a tactic in northern western
province of Italy not necessarily just
to make military gains but his ultimate
aim was to push those displaced Syrians
to cross into Turkey and then Turkey
will find itself grappling with millions
and millions of Syrian Syrians in its
territory and that's why they had to
send troops on the ground number two
they say that they are pretty much
concerned that the offensive that was
launched by the Syrian government would
create destabilization across the area
on the border and for them it was
instrumental to move in and to secure
the border with Syria and I think this
is something that resonates among many
people that we remains to be seen we
have to wait and see what happens from
midnight are we going to see some of the
Turkish soldiers redeployed back into
Turkey are they going to maintain their
position how are they going to talk
about those observation post and is the
general sentiment in Turkey receptive to
the idea of maintaining troops in Italy
for as long as it takes until there is a
final political solution that would put
an end to the civil war in the country